Flowers is comedy it's a sitcom that I
feel like tries to break out of its own
format it centers around a family and it
looks at I think that three main themes
are probably family and the idea of home
and mental illness it's set in its own
sort of world and a big part of making
flowers I think was us working together
try to build that world in a cohesive
way and recently I've started to wonder
if a helpful way of talking about it is
as a comedy wizard mental illness in
that if I'm with a funny person and they
start talking to me about I'm having a
hard time or about a serious issue I
don't think of them as not a funny
person I think of them as talking to me
about having a hard time it's always
quite hard to work out I think where an
idea comes from but one of the first
things that I remember about flowers is
having an image of the house in this
kind of slightly bleak landscape kind of
heathen landscape and that was I suppose
one of the key parts of building the
world of flowers was trying to find this
location which took a while and in many
ways is quite an impractical house to
film in because the ceilings are very
low in fact they're so low that Julian
he's quite tall Julian Barratt who plays
Morris the father has to stoop a little
bit on some of the levels and we often
say that the house is a little bit like
a character in itself the character of
shown I think was born out of my desire
to inject into the show a sense of the
Japanese comedies as that I grew up
watching as a kid I lived in Tokyo I was
eight years old and so some of my
earliest comedy memories are these
really silly Japanese sketch shows and
in the end it felt like probably the
easiest way to incorporate onto the show
was to create the character of shown and
then I think like all of the
other characters did he started to sort
of challenge his position in the sitcom
and sort of show me other aspects of his
character and I think he's partly a
comment maybe on the sort of comedic
representation of Asians in on the
Western screen perhaps in that I wanted
to sort of - I suppose present at first
a slightly stylized personality and then
to kind of evolve him into a
three-dimensional character I'm
extremely lucky I think to have had a
the opportunity to have made this show
and be to have been able to share it
with such an extraordinary group of
people and I think all over cast Julian
Barratt Olivia Colman Tony Rigby Sofia
DiMartino everybody are extremely funny
but also have depth and I think their
performances are key in our sort of us
trying to strike a balance between the
light and the dark between the comedic
moments and the more dramatic moments if
you like and the other thing to say I
think is that everyone who worked on the
show cast and crew were extremely a sort
of generous spirited and kind-hearted
and I think particularly on the second
series having made the first series
together there was a kind of sense of
automatic trust which really helped us I
think to navigate our way through the
story and to just sort of know that you
could rely on the other people to
support you in your decisions and I
think perhaps partly that was born out
of the subject material that the flowers
is is very much about family in
relationships and and the idea of home
but it's also in part I think about
mental illness and what I'd love the
audience to get from the show I think is
a sense of that warmth that I felt from
the people that I was making it with
sometimes I use the analogy of maybe of
working in music perhaps or
in a band or something we're writing the
music doesn't always preclude you from
performing it and if you want to have a
hand in producing it and mixing it and
that's something that you enjoy then
that sometimes happens as well and
obviously writing directing acting
they're all slightly different
disciplines but I see them in some ways
as part of the same thing which is just
telling storytelling and and making
something and so I see for me I've
always worked on some project in that
way so it doesn't it doesn't feel
strange to me and obviously it's an
extremely collaborative process from the
development of the scripts through
perhaps through the shoot through the
Edit into post-production it's you're
constantly having conversations with
heads of department would produce us
with the channel and I think what what
we wanted to do with flowers was to make
sure that we were always cross
pollinating ideas so that we could build
this cohesive world and it relied on us
I think just being able to communicate
and so you know I'm extremely supported
I think an affair extremely supported
both in a practical sense and in an
emotional sense and so I think the
people that I was working with make it
easier the only times that I find being
in a scene difficult when I'm directing
something is because often I feel like
you could judge a take partly on just
the chemistry of the of the seed and how
it felt to perform with the other people
and I find it difficult is when sureness
is playing very small part in quite a
big group scene or a complicated scene
because I can't judge it based on the
chemistry but I also have to make sure
that I'm standing the right place say my
lines so I can't observe it either and
so on the first series I would sometimes
write scenes where she would enter
briefly and then exit because I thought
that would mean that I could go from the
monitor into the scene back to the
monitor but the reality of filming means
that you know I would be running 200
yards Retta house by the time I got to
the monitor seemed to be over so
I tried to be mindful of that in the
writing of the second series as well as
in in a sort of on the shoot as well the
first series of flowers was set in in a
kind of wintery autumnal time and the
palette reflected that was quite a cool
palette there's the the second series
one of the first things I knew about it
was that I wanted it to be set in a
different season and I wanted it to look
slightly different so the palette is
warmer the colors are more vivid and I
think that was partly because I wanted
the first series to feel for the
audience like a kind of memory as it
would for the characters and so that was
one of the ways I felt I was trying to
achieve that as well as making the
characters look slightly different where
the first series looked into depression
a bit through the character of Morris
and the strains that I put on his
relationship with Deborah just who
Olivia commonplaces wife
the second series focuses a little bit
more on manic depression or bipolar as
it's known now known and I felt like
there kind of the warm palette the vivid
colors the music and the sound are a big
part of the second series I wanted it to
be a really sensory experience for the
for the audience and to try to give them
a sense of what it might feel like to
experience to experience hypomania I
suppose so I think the second series is
more ambitious in many ways both in a in
a practical sense and in a thematic way
and the characters I always say it feels
like that the characters have their own
agency and they're leading me to where
they want to go and they really do I
think take us to new places in the in
the second in the second series I'm
constantly research to write a script
and how hard it is to get a script to
the point where it feels like it was
easy and I think for me anyway it takes
it takes a lot of time it feels like it
it takes me showing up which is a
computer and just putting in the hours
and trusting that
even if it doesn't come immediately
which it rarely ever does that the
answer will come if I if I go into that
world and if I put myself in the shoes
of those characters and spend enough
time in there that the answers will
arrive and I think the people around you
are invaluable as well you know people
to bounce off people to ask questions to
people to feedback on the material
that's always I think even if you don't
agree with someone's opinion it's an
opportunity to improve the script and
not a sort of attack to be defended and
so I think it just takes time and just a
supposed a degree of faith like I think
I've got I've got used to the fact that
it's not going to happen straightaway
and that for me was almost what felt
like the sort of shift from doing it as
a kind of hobby to doing it seriously
was that okay I'm just going to put in
as many hours as it takes and the thing
is I think if you really want to do it
and you really love writing you will
happily sit there until it's done until
you're happy with it basically I love
directing because I think it's it's all
about the other people and it's about
getting the best out of the people
around you and listening to them and
it's such a delightful part of the
process for me because it just involves
a sort of having fun talking about ideas
and being surprised by you know other
people's input I think I think what
makes a good director is having the
confidence not to over impose your own
ideas or your own restrictions on the
actors and heads of department whoever
it is and to trust that you have your
sort of you have a reactive
responsibility to sort of try to get the
best out of them I really think that the
assembling of a team whether it's the
cast or the crew is is a huge part of of
any creative project you know on flowers
we were you know partly assembling a
team on
purpose of people who we thought would
be extremely good at their jobs and that
we thought we would get on with and but
I think there is also a certain amount
of luck involved and it's important to
try to make sure that you have a
chemistry in to sort of test that before
you commit to working together but then
how that evolves into an experience I
think is is partly down to being open
and being willing to be vulnerable with
each other and to trust each other and
to be able to be honest in a tactful way
and trust that it won't hurt anyone's
feelings but it's also you know like you
will be making a show directing is I
always feel like at kind of 90 percent
just problem solving because there's a
relentless it's just the sort of
challenges will be thrown at you every
single day and it sort of how you deal
with them if if you're able to sort of
handle them as a group work together to
sort of solve a problem without
panicking then I think that is like a
huge part of making it a success and
yeah I mean I've said it before but I
just feel extremely lucky on flowers
because I think we really had that and
we really did work together and that was
partly by design but also I think just
extremely good fortune
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]